the president of el salvador on friday
when they noticed that the price was
dipping decided to go ahead and launch
another buy order the country of el
salvador has bought 100 bitcoin during
the price dip quite literally we were
watching a nation state buy the dip
absolutely incredible and not only did
he go when he buy the dip but then he
tweeted it so he is essentially mocking
or
poking the bear saying el salvador just
bought the dip 100 extra coins acquired
with a discount little celebration emoji
bitcoin now when we see this he was
buying somewhere around 54 55 000
to remember el salvador now owns
1220 bitcoin all together that is a
pretty material position as the price of
bitcoin continues to rise now they are
not just buying bitcoin the country of
el salvador continues to also do a
number of other things around bitcoin
they've got the chivo wallet they've
built they've got a network of about 200
atms they've installed all around the
country they are onboarding now over 50
of their 6.5 million citizens have
actually downloaded the chivo wallet and
have bitcoin sitting in there on top of
that they also have built a mining
facility in one of their power
generations where there is use of
volcano energy or geothermal energy and
then on top of that they made it legal
tender in the country they continue to
do all sorts of crazy stuff that ends up
being pretty positive for the country
but more importantly is they just
announced bitcoin city now what is
bitcoin city they are going to build an
entire city based on bitcoin and what
that looks like is it is going to be
built on their land they will have no
income property capital gains or payroll
taxes and in order to help fund some of
this they are issuing a one billion
dollar bitcoin backed bond what that
looks like is they will basically raise
a billion dollars they will take half of
it 500 million they will buy bitcoin the
other half will be used to build
infrastructure bitcoin mining and other
types of things and then over time they
will pay
bond holders a 6.5 yield plus a special
bitcoin dividend as they sell the
bitcoin in the future this is absolutely
incredible because not only are we
watching them do very innovative things
like bitcoin city or bitcoin back bonds
not only are we watching them make it
legal tender and build out things like
chivo and the atm network but on top of
that
they continue to buy more bitcoin and
when the price drops
naib bukelli is there to buy the dip
and of course
he understands the internet he
understands memes and he's firing off
this one saying hey you guys got stunks
i got bitcoin it's pretty cool what'd
you guys think when you saw him just
firing tweets off saying that they
bought another 100 bitcoin on the dip i
mean it's not surprising right they're
clearly all in at this point uh there's
a number of different things that they
could do i guess that that would
accelerate this plan but at this point i
think everyone is very clear what their
conviction is regarding the asset and
their uh their ability and willingness
to implement it kind of within their
economy so yeah like i mean he's done
this before he every time he keeps
tweeting it out he knows how the
internet's gonna react he knows it's
kind of just free marketing to him at
some point especially with the price
appreciating and what we've seen has
been tremendous for them uh as a country
right you mentioned it previously over
50 percent of their citizens more people
in their country now have digital
wallets bitcoin wallets than they have
traditional bank accounts which i think
is fascinating right especially in the
short period of time it's only been a
few months hasn't even been a year yet
since they rolled this program out it's
been three or four months whatever it is
right so the adoption uh has been really
good and strong and i think part of that
was obviously aided by their willingness
to give away i think it was thirty
dollars in bitcoin or whatever it is
right but that's a small incentive to
onboard millions of people to your app
right and you've said this previously
but if a technology company was to do
that their valuation would be a billion
dollars worth already right because of
that ability to quickly scale up and
we're seeing that aggressively within el
salvador so i think whether you agree
with kind of their approach it's a
fascinating case study and i think you
at least have to appreciate the
conviction that uh that they're giving
this and just saying hey screw we're
going all in uh this is our our kind of
standpoint on this and what we've seen
is any technology like this that ends up
working out not only does it have strong
network effects but the first kind of uh
people who go all in the people the
michael sailors the people who adapt
these technologies and say hey we're
going to transform everything we do and
we're going to go for this those are the
people who have who benefit the most
from these things so i think it'll be
fascinating to see as bitcoin continues
to evolve and continues to get global
adoption continues to increase in price
and all of that kind of stuff where this
puts el salvador kind of on the rankings
of countries throughout the world right
because they're very low from a uh kind
of a however you look at however you
look at it from an economic perspective
right now and i think this has the
chance outside of everything that
they've ever done to really move them
further up that list john what do you
think
the el salvadorians i think is how you
say that salvadorians salvadorians the
salvadorians that have held bitcoin
since september 7th when they uh kind of
released this whole project after making
it legal tender are up 20
on their on their investment on their
asset and they've never seen an
appreciation like that it's amazing to
see and him buying the dip is not
surprising at all to me i think he'll
continue to do this he's clearly going
all in with bitcoin city and other
things that he's been able to um
implement in his country and look he's
he's he understands the internet and
this is the game that i think we're
gonna see play out over the next 20
years is how many politicians how many
countries how many companies go more
into the marketing that the internet and
social media can provide because it's a
massive network of people that you reach
globally rather than a billboard on the
side of the street it makes absolute 100
sense that he's buying the dip based on
his conviction based on what he's done
in the past and i i can see him just
continuing to double down double down
again and again and that's what i think
we'll see the the piece of this that's
uh uh i continue to say is that when he
does this he's plugging his country into
the bitcoin network right by doing a
kind of very robust uh total strategy
not just hey we're gonna buy bitcoin not
just saying hey we're gonna build the
atms not just saying hey we're gonna
make a legal tender by doing all of it
he is literally taking an entire nation
state he's plugging it into the bitcoin
network when he plugs his nation state
into the bitcoin network he is hiring
millions of people around the world to
go to work for him they're cheering for
his success they're building software
for them they're building infrastructure
they're securing his money either going
ahead and they're actually visiting his
country they're trying to help build
things they're going to buy his bonds
he's literally plugging the entire
nation state into the bitcoin network
and i think what we're going to watch
and see is that over a long period of
time 20 30 years we're going to look
back and say that strategy ended up
being incredibly valuable for the people
who went ahead and did it
agree completely agree yeah joe you
agree too yeah i agree i think the the
most important point is from a citizen's
perspective right and for the first time
in their entire lives no matter how old
they are they are seeing their
purchasing power appreciate for the
first time right and i think that's a
massive point because everyone wants to
point to oh bitcoin went down two
percent today or five percent today how
would it feel to see your wealth
diminish like that in a day but when you
zoom out and you look at when they
started adopting this standard and where
we are today versus where we might be in
five 10 15 years as this continues to
get adopted globally with a finite
constrained supply you start to really
understand wow this could really change
the lives of a lot of people in their
country well i'd be interested to see
what country does in venezuela right
other countries that are experiencing
hyperinflation when do they plug into
the bitcoin network
when you see something like this happen
it's a no-brainer for other countries to
explore it and then take it take action
on it i'm shocked that venezuela
zimbabwe turkey you know one of these
countries that's really really
struggling right now they don't just
print a ton and go buy bitcoin in the
market
like the speculative attack on it would
would uh venezuela knock in six six
zeroes off their currency right